[Music]
honestly it kind of sucks waking up on a
monday morning and not having any
lovecraft country episodes to watch
however there is still a lot to talk
about now if you followed our breakdowns
on the series
then you'll know that i absolutely fell
in love with it and i was so happy to
see it divert from the source material
towards the end of the season
as it opens up so many possibilities
we're going to be getting into it all
throughout this video but if you're new
here
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul i just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking the
breakdown
and i i hope you enjoy it okay so the
first question i had as a fan of the
book was
is atticus actually dead in addition to
this i want to talk about christina
who seemingly lost her life in the show
now
skip ahead about 30 seconds if you don't
want things from the original novel
spoiled
as i know a lot of you are probably
reading that right now and don't want it
ruined
are you still here great well sod those
other people yeah don't tell them i said
that
though but in the book
it actually ends on quite a high note
now all of the characters survive
even caleb who is the basis of christina
and the work closes out with the main
group all driving off into the sunset
as they go on another road trip now why
this happens
is because captain lancaster is actually
propped up as the big bad of the finale
and the group work with caleb in order
to kill him however they also double
cross caleb
strip him of his powers and then drop
him off in the middle of indiana by
himself
now the original work doesn't really set
up the need for a sequel
but with showrunner misha green teasing
that she has ideas of where she wants to
go with it
i do think that there are a lot of
possibilities now personally i think
that both atticus
and christina are dead and gone for good
when the kumio comes out of gr
we do get flashes of their lives and
though i have seen some people say that
these good teas feature events
they're actually all moments from the
past now firstly is atticus getting
baptized
then him teaching diana to control the
shoghorth christina catching ruby
tick handing over his letter to
hippolyta and ruby putting the mark of
kane back on letty
these were all key plot points in the
finale and with the kumio only seeing
the past
and not the future i think it rules out
the possibility that either will be back
typically along with the past gr would
also see the future
and this is how she was able to
determine tick's fate with the future
being absent from all of her visions in
the final episode
i do think that it confirms that neither
he or christina will be coming back
we also know from tick's son george who
wrote the novel lovecraft
country that in this timeline the
character is dead and gone
now you're probably wondering why i've
spent so long talking about this in a
predictions video
but it leads me into my main theory
which is that the show will take place
in a completely different time to the
first season
we know from tick's journey to the
future that there are mass riots
breaking out
and that diana is the one leading these
i believe that
season 2 will center around tick and let
his son george
as he tries to retrace the steps of his
parents in order to write his book
this would allow for him to travel
across the country to notable locations
but it could also be instrumental in why
the riots break out
now we know from the finale that all the
magical white people
have been stripped of their powers and
are now unable to use them
they likely just woke up and have
absolutely no
idea what caused this to happen or where
it even came from
thus they can't really blame black
people and i think that it will have
flown under the radar for the next 20 or
30 years
with the secret remaining hidden i
actually think that george's journey
will unearth what happened to his father
and in doing so he too will uncover what
happened to strip white people
of their abilities upon publishing the
book this could be brought to light
and then it will cause a lot of racial
tensions as the whites will be angered
that they had their powers stripped
this would cause things to explode and
lead to the riots
that tick came across now this is
actually teased by diana in the show
when we catch you reading lovecraft
country just before the shoguth attack
she reads out loud that they would have
to spill the blood of a warlock
in order to upset the hierarchy and this
is of course why she kills christina in
the finale
in addition to this we also know that
diana is part of the riots
and that she likely has her shogut with
her i actually think that the ending
teases her upcoming character arc
and whilst it initially seems as a
triumphant moment with her killing
christina
the subtext is a lot darker for me diana
has gone through a lot in the season
as not only did she lose her arm to the
warlocks she also lost her father
there's no doubt gonna be a lot of anger
there and due to the power she now
possesses
in both her arm and shoggoth sidekick i
really think that she's gonna be the one
leading the charge for her people
i think there's a lot of possibilities
there and diana might even become an
anti-hero that george has
to wrestle with i think it would be
great if they set up a sort of malcolm x
motif in diana
and had george becoming the martin
luther king of the show
as it would be a good way to betray both
sides of the civil rights movement
now i could just be reading into that
but watching the sugar
howl at the moon is both terrifying and
yet
somehow triumphant at the same time you
really get the feeling that diana
who represents a new generation is not
going to take things lying down
instead i think that she will not let
the white people in the show get away
with how they've treated their people
and will fight back though this could
lead to her being a villain perhaps
i actually have a theory that we sort of
already know who the big bad is gonna be
and that is caleb braithwight now if
you're a fan of the book like me
then when we were first introduced to
christina you are probably questioning
why one of the main characters in the
work
had just been gender swapped i quickly
brushed this to the side when i realized
that they were using christina to
explore gender roles
and white feminism but something was
just gnawing away at me
and by the end i was a bit disappointed
we didn't get caleb pop up in any shape
or form
now i would absolutely love it if the
villain of the second season was caleb
and we discovered that he was a relative
of the bright whites
who through george learned that they
were the reason for his family's
downfall
season one was very much about white
privilege at points
and the second season could deal with a
character who believes that he should
have an upper hand in life
but that this has been stripped away
because of equality
in the last couple of years we've seen
that there's been a massive amount of
people
that have acted like they're losing out
because other races and genders are
getting more right
i think that the show could explore how
some people react negatively
to others gaining equality now if you're
enjoying the video
then i would absolutely love it if you
subscribe to the channel
as it massively helps us out we're
trying to hit the 400 000 mark by the
end of the year
and it would mean the world to me if you
did that so so thank you if you do
anyway on top of all this we could also
explore the multiverse through hippolyta
and it is possible that she could travel
to either our world or the book universe
in which all the characters are still
alive i also think that it would be
amazing if the tick from the past showed
up at one point in season two
and diana gave him the book
alternatively the character could have
been lying to montrose
and though he said he was only there for
a couple of seconds he actually could
have been there for a while
he did go into the portal and come out
much much later
so he may have spent a lot more time on
the other side then he said that he did
take of course knew how things were
going to play out and he did his
sacrifice willingly
so there is a reason there why he might
have covered certain things up
and lastly is gr who i really hope pops
up again
we did learn from the shaman that she
would need to take the lives of 100 men
in order to lift the curse
and that upon doing so she would become
something different
i actually count tick as the 100th man
and thus
there is a lot they can do with their
character from now on
michigan did state that if there was a
second season
that it would explore asian americans i
think through gr
and most likely her children that they
have an opportunity to do this
whatever happens i really hope that we
get a second season
and a third one for that matter as the
show was so good
and there's so many other historical
things that they can touch upon
lovecraft country is very relevant today
i'd love to see them do more with the
characters and also this universe
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts and theories so make sure you
comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then
definitely check out our breakdown of
the final episode which is going to be
linked at the end
we go over the entire entry and break
down all the things you missed
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more don't forget we're
also giving away three copies of the
marvel phase one box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below the winner is going to be chosen
at random on the 30th of october
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content like this
early then please consider clicking the
join button below you can also come chat
to us on our discord link
or at heavyspoilers on twitter thanks
for making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you